welcome back and in the last couple of
videos actually the very first video in
centripetal acceleration I told you that
the the necessary centripetal
acceleration and we're just talking
about the magnitude and actually the C
tells you the direction right its
centripetal so it's inward acceleration
it equals the velocity squared over the
radius and I told you that you know the
real rigorous proof has to be done with
calculus but I looked on Wikipedia and
there's actually a pretty neat proof
although when you read Wikipedia it's
not so obvious on what they're saying so
I thought I would do a video on it
because this is cool and you don't need
calculus to understand it so let's let's
just do something and let's just plot
the the distance vector the velocity
vectors and the acceleration vectors as
something goes around a circle so let me
draw two circles so let's say this is my
first circle let me draw another circle
and in another color just for fun okay
it's my other circle this is the center
circle and this is the center of the
circle and so what's the position vector
at any point in time well the position
vector you could kind of just draw it as
a radius so the position vector at any
given time looks something like this so
let's say initially this is the position
vector that's the initial position
vector its magnitude is the radius of
the circle and its direction is like
it's in this in the right here in the
positive x-direction and then at that
point what is the velocity vector well
the velocity let's assume we're going
counterclockwise I don't know why I
assumed that it could go the other way
let's say this is the velocity vector at
that point the velocity vector is going
to look something like that
that is the velocity vector that's V
alright it's going tangent to the circle
well let's plot that same let let's plot
the velocity vector as a function of
time on this circle so if that's the
velocity vector at that time I'm gonna I
can draw the velocity vector here this
is same vector remember I'm just saying
it at a particular time what is the
distance vector look like what does the
velocity vector look like so at that
time the velocity vector looks like this
and I'm trying to make it the same size
to show use the same vector and I'm
doing into the same color to show you so
same vector right this is the exact same
vector this is the actual circle like if
you were to draw this is the path of the
you know the dot or whatever is moving
around the circle and this is you could
just kind of view it as I'm plotting the
velocity over time the velocity vector
over time so let's draw well let's see
it say a few seconds later or a few
moments later what does the radius
vector look like well then the radius
vector looks like this
the radius vector looks like this I'm
try and draw it as neatly as possible
just now what does the velocity vector
look like go back did the purple the
velocity vector once again is tangent to
the circle and it'll look something like
that it's gonna have the same magnitude
just different direction actually let me
do it in a different color
just to show you what I'm doing so let
me let me do it in in brown so the
velocity vector is going to look
something like this that's a brown
supposed to be a brown that's the loss
of vector so after a few seconds or a
few moments what it where's the velocity
vector here what's gonna look like this
remember this this factor I'm just
plotting it here after a few seconds
check out the line tool so it's the same
magnitude and it's the now the velocity
is just at a different angle and then it
should be the exact same angle is what I
just drew in the other circle
right and I'm going through so that's
this velocity vector right so when we
start here the velocities will change at
the circle after a few moments the
objects rotating around the circle so
now the velocity is the same magnitude
it's just switch directions and so
what's happening here when we plot the
velocity vector over time it has the
same magnitude so it'll it'll draw out a
circle but its direction changes so what
is just as in this case what takes us
from this point to this point this was
the velocity vector and the velocity
vector is always changing but in general
this is the change in position and what
causes the change of position well the
velocity releases speed because the
vector is always changing so in this
case what's changing the velocity well
just like velocity changes radius
acceleration changes velocity all right
so let me draw an acceleration vector
and the acceleration is going to be in
this direction right because if the
velocity is changing from here to here
the acceleration is kind of going along
the direction of the change in velocity
so the acceleration vector might look
something like that it's going to be
tangent to this velocity path alright
and that's interesting too because if
this is the acceleration vector that
when the velocities here so when the
velocities here the acceleration vector
is going directly to the left so then
that means that the acceleration vector
is going directly to the left and so
this is also the acceleration vector
which it coincides with what we learned
about centripetal acceleration the
acceleration has to be going inwards and
we see that when we actually plot the
velocity vector and if we plot the
acceleration vector here once again it's
going to be going tangent to this plot
of the velocity vector well let me do it
in a different color I've already used
that color in yellow so then the
acceleration vector is going to look
something like this remember
acceleration is nothing but change in
velocity so at this point when this is
the velocity vector the acceleration
vector will just be this and once again
it's it's it's it's just in the opposite
direction of the position vector so why
am i doing all this well I'm doing all
of this to set up the analogy to show
you as this object come
pleats one entire path what's happening
on this circle well this circle the
velocity is completing one entire path
right however long it takes to go around
this circle is the same amount of time
it takes to go from this velocity back
to this velocity right the magnitude is
the same the whole time but the
direction is changing so if this takes
10 seconds to go around the circle in
real position then it takes 10 seconds
for the acceleration to change the
direction of this velocity enough that
it goes back and to the original
velocity direction so why am i doing all
that well how long does it take for the
object to do one one one rotation around
this path well it's just the distance
divided by the velocity right so the
time to do one revolution around this
path is the distance well that's just
the circumference of the circle well
that's 2 PI R divided by your speed
which is V and so and what's how much
time does it take to go around this path
well we know it's going to be the same
time right and it and now we're going to
say it's it the time is going to be the
change in velocity right here in this
circle
we're plot this is the change in
distance but it's the change in velocity
so here we had this much change in
velocity I know this might be a little
bit non-intuitive then we have a little
bit more change in velocity a little bit
more change in velocity a little bit
more change in velocity so the the total
change in velocity is just going to is
the circumference of this circle and
what's the circumference of this circle
well the radius of the circle is the
magnitude of the velocity so it's 2 pi
times the velocity of the circle and so
what is that the amount of time it takes
to do a 1 revolution was the total
change in velocity and that's 2 tot pi
times the magnitude of velocity divided
by acceleration and if this does make
complete sense you just remember
acceleration is change in velocity over
change in time and it's a little it's a
little I'm glossing over a little bit
because
you might say oh well the net change in
velocity is zero but we're actually
concerned about kind of how what's the
total change in the velocity so it kind
of it changes a lot and then it goes
back to its original so that the net is
still zero but this should hopefully
give you a little intuition so think
about what I said but the bottom line is
we know that this expression and this
expression have to be equal because in
the same amount of time it takes the
object to do one complete revolution on
this circle its velocity Direction has
also done one complete revolution so we
can set these two equal to each other so
we could say 2 pi R over V is equal to 2
pi V over a let me switch colors we can
cross the 2 pi out on both sides and
then we could melt multiply both sides
times V you get R is equal to V squared
over a multiply both sides times a I'm
doing this a little bit circuitous Li
and you get AR is equal to V squared and
divide both sides by R and you get a is
equal to V squared over R so hopefully
that gives you a little bit of intuition
about that why this works and I got this
from Wikipedia so I want to give them
proper credit and hopefully my
explanation helps clarify what the
people on Wikipedia are talking about a
little bit anyway I also do the calculus
proof because that's kind of more you
know just straight-up math and I'll see
in the next video